all right I think there's been an
exciting video in this video you see how
to implement gradient descent for your
neural network with one hidden layer in
this video I'm going to just give you
the equations you need to implement in
order to get that propagation of the jet
gradient descent working and then in the
video after this one or give some more
intuition about why these particular
equations are the accurate equations or
the correct equations for computing the
gradients you need for your neural
network so your neural network with a
single hidden layer for now will have
parameters W 1 V 1 W 2 and B 2 and so as
a reminder if you have an X alternative
the UM n 0 input features and N 1 hidden
units and n 2 output units in our
example so following it n 2 equals 1
then the matrix W 1 will be N 1 by n 0 B
1 will be an N 1 dimensional vector so
you can write down as a 10 1 by 1
dimensional matrix really a column
vector the dimensions of W 2 will be n 2
by N 1 and the dimension of B 2 will be
n 2 by 1 right where again so far we've
only seen examples where n 2 is equal to
one where you have just one a single
hidden unit so you also have a cost
function for a neural network and for
now I'm just going to assume that you're
doing binary classification so in that
case the cost of your parameters as
follows is going to be 1 over m of the
average of that loss function and so L
here is the loss when your new network
predicts y hat all right this is really
a a to when the ground should label is e
to the Y and if you're doing binary
classification the loss function can be
exactly what you use for logistic
earlier so to crane the parameters your
algorithms you need to perform gradient
descent when training your network is
important to initialize the parameters
randomly rather than to all the URLs
will say later why that's the case but
after initializing the parameter to
something each loop or gradient descent
would compute the predictions
so you basically compute you know y hat
I for I equals 1 through m say and then
you need to compute the derivative so
you need to compute DW 1 and that's this
is a derivative of the cost function
with respect to the parameter w1 you
need to compute another variable which
is going to call B b1 which is the
derivative or the slope of your cost
function with respect to the variable B
1 and so on similarly for the other
parameters W 2 and B 2 and then finally
the gradient descent update would be to
update W 1 as W 1 minus alpha the
learning rate times d w1 b1 gets updated
as b1 minus the learning rate times D b1
and similarly for W 2 and B 2 and
sometimes I use colon equals and
sometimes equals as either either the
notation works fine and so this would be
one iteration of gradient descent and
then you repeat this some number of
times until your parameters look like
they're converging so in previous videos
we talked about how to compute
predictions how to compute the outputs
and we saw how to do that in a
vectorized way as well so the key is to
know how to compute these partial
derivative terms the DW 1 DB 1 as well
as the derivatives BW 2 and DP 2 so what
I'd like to do is just give you the
equations you need in order to compute
these derivatives and I'll defer to the
next video which is an optional video to
go greater into Jeff about how we came
up with those formulas so then just
summarize again the equations for
for propagation so you have z1 equals W
1x plus B 1 and then a 1 equals the
activation function in that layer
applied other than Y since V 1 and then
Z 2 equals W 2 A 1 plus B 2 and then
finally this is all vectorize across
your training set right a 2 is equal to
G 2 of Z 2 the game for now if we assume
you're doing binary classification then
this activation function really should
be the sigmoid function so I'm just
throw that in 0 so that the forward
propagation or the left-to-right forward
computation for your neural network next
let's compute the derivatives so this is
the back propagation step we're going to
compute D Z 2 equals a 2 minus the
ground truth Y and just just as a
reminder all this is vectorize across
example so the matrix Y is the sum 1 by
M matrix then this all of your M
examples stacked horizontally then it
turns out DW 2 is equal to this in fact
um these first three equations are very
similar to gradient descent for logistic
regression
come on X is equals 1 comma um chickens
equals true and just a little detail
this NP dot some is a Python numpy
come-on for something across one
dimension of a matrix in this case
something horizontally and what keep
dims does is it prevents python from
outputting one of those funny rank 1
arrays where where the dimensions was
you know n comma
so by having keep them as equals true
this ensures that Python outputs for db2
a vector that is sum n by one
technically this will be I guess n to
buy one in this case is just a one by
one number so maybe it doesn't matter
but later on we'll see when it really
matters so so far what we've done is
very similar to logistic regression but
now as you compute two new to run back
propagation you would compute this easy
two times G one prime of Z 1 so this
quantity G 1 prime is the derivative of
whatever was the activation function you
use for the hidden layer and for the
output layer I assume that you're doing
binary classification with the sigmoid
function so that's already baked into
that formula for DZ 2 and this times is
a element-wise product so this here is
going to be an N 1 by M matrix and this
here this element wise derivative thing
is also going to be an N 1 by n matrix
and so this times there is an element
wise products of two matrices then
finally DW 1 is equal to that and DB 1
is equal to this and P dot some D Z 1 X
is equals 1
keep this equals true so we're
previously the keep dinners maybe matter
less if n 2 is equal to 1 so just one by
one thing is there's a real number here
pp 1 will be a N 1 by 1 vector and so
you want Python you want n P dot some
output something of this dimension
rather than a family right one array of
that dimension which could end up
messing up some of your basic
calculations the other way would be to
not have to keep them parameters but to
explicitly call in a reshape to reshape
the output of and P dot some into this
dimension which you would like dB so how
so that was more propagation in I guess
four equations and back propagation in I
guess six equations I knew I just wrote
down these equations but in the next
optional video let's go over some
intuitions for how the six equations for
the back propagation algorithm were
derived please feel free to watch that
or not but either way if you implement
these algorithms you will have a correct
implementation of four prop and back
prop and you'll be able to compute the
derivative you need in order to apply
gradient descent to learn the parameters
of your neural network it is possible to
implement design room and get it to work
without deeply understanding the
calculus a lot of successful deep
learning practitioners do so but if you
want you can also watch the next video
just to get a bit more intuition about
the derivation of these of these
equations